question is
on the topic of suffering and growth
is happiness a healthy pursuit or do you
agree with
einstein's view on happiness as the
aspiration of a pig
okay let me quickly look up the einstein
quote here
that you reference about a pig and
happiness
okay einstein writes i have never looked
upon
ease and happiness as ends in themselves
this critical basis i call the ideal of
a pigsty
the ideals that have lighted my way and
time after time have given me new
courage to face
life cheerfully have been kindness
beauty
and truth without the sense of kinship
with men of like mind
without the occupation with the
objective world the eternally
unattainable
in the field of art and scientific
endeavors life would have
seemed empty to me the trite objects of
human efforts
possessions outward success luxury
have always seemed to me contemptible
okay where do i start with this i think
i usually agree with einstein
especially when he talks philosophy on
most things and i do hear as well
in terms of material possessions and all
those kinds of things
but i think he unfairly attacks the word
happiness and also
pigs so let me uh
disagree with einstein and try to defend
the word happiness and also maybe defend
pigs
if i can somehow figure that out so
the word happiness
i think is one of those words that could
mean a lot of things to a lot of people
and i think in this case einstein is
using it as almost uh
or the pursuit of happiness as a kind of
synonym for
hedonism so kind of very narrow
definition of what happiness is
i think i see happiness as a
indicator that it's much bigger than uh
then direct pleasures but as a word that
includes those pleasures but also
includes more meaningful deep
fulfillment in life
and so i'd like to reclaim the word
happiness as a good thing
which is slightly applied in this
discussion that
happiness is a kind of distraction that
shouldn't be thought about
i do think that happiness is a side
effect
of a life well-lived not a goal
i think the moment it becomes a goal in
itself i think it's easy to lose your
way
and perhaps that's what in part einstein
means
but i do think it's a really good signal
of progress
happiness so in um
losing yourself in the focus of battle
of just focusing on
excellence and progress and improving
and
challenging yourself and growing all the
time
i think a kind of
running average measure of your
happiness day-to-day happiness you like
average that over a period of weeks and
months
is a good measure of how you're doing
and i think a more like actionable
process
of collecting that signal is the process
of just gratitude of sitting back
and thinking how grateful i am how
grateful you are
for uh for how it started and how it's
going
for the progress uh that you've made so
i do think it's a good signal
not momentary happens but over a period
of time several weeks several months
if there's not happiness that you've
probably lost your way as well
so it's a useful signal not a goal in
itself but a useful
signal and you know kindness beauty and
truth
as einstein puts it are good ideals
but they're a bit ambiguous in a
practical day-to-day sense i share them
of course
but i think practically if i were to put
it into words at least for myself
struggle is the process
uh happiness is
the measure so day to day
life actually looks like a constant
struggle to improve yourself
and then the flip side of that
is the gratitude of how amazing
life is the progress you've made but
also just the opportunity
to struggle as uh you know
you have to imagine sis was happy and
ultimately when i look back at my life
most days i spent
truly happy to be alive
so in that sense the pursuit of
happiness is a good one
so not hedonistic in the moment
local optima of kind of pleasure
but more like stepping back looking at
the running average
over the past few weeks and months and
making sure you're at a good level
so that's a bit of a disagreement with
einstein
and i also have to say that i think
pigs are one of the most intelligent
animals
so i'm still holding out for the
possibility that uh pigs
or maybe dolphins have uh life figured
out
quite a bit better than us humans
so on those two things the pursuit of
happiness and
on the brilliance of pigs me and
einstein part ways
for a brief moment
you